Jason's with us in New York hi Jason
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show better
than I deserve what's up I'm you know
I'm pretty sure you're gonna yell at me
about something selfish but it's a
correlated issue I make um 51 5 a year I
got myself into with $62,000
Carlos Wow what kind of car did BMW nice
ok I do not have any other debt at all
I've actually used my credit card last
year to buy the car put it down payment
on the car which was about $5,000 I take
it off $5,000 on the crumb I paid the
whole credit card off and then I'm also
what the card arm loan down to about 55
right now unfortunately since I carried
over a negative a lot of negative equity
and you know do a lot some you know the
warranty in there it ended up being I'm
at this point upside down on that
vehicle at least 25 case well my
question to you is since I'm making some
Lorraine I don't have any other debt in
the car should I just continue pushing
through and paid off or just get out of
the car and you know try it another way
you bought an additional warranty yeah I
haven't thrown a warranty in there how
much is that that one it would the
warranty was for an additional five
years unlimited miles for 3500 bucks
okay so we can cancel that and that'll
cut down some of your upside down and
you're telling me that this car that you
paid how much for what did you pay for
the car the actual course of the
physical car itself yeah what was the
price of the car oh the carbon the
carbon our money the car driving the BMW
having a negative equity the car honey
not negative equity not financing what
was the price of the freaking car yeah
it's forty forty five thousand dollars
okay and so you your 60 thousand dollars
was you had a negative equity already a
fifteen year old
yes okay that's what I was trying to get
to and so from 45 it's gone down to 25
in one year a bit down it's down to it's
down to the trade-in value even if I was
in selling private sale it's about it's
at about 35 but I old 55 went on 10
grand in a year yes
which model of Beamer is this it's in
seven series okay that's our man that's
just a car up they should have held its
value better than that I'm a little
shocked okay so you owe 55 - say five
for this warranty gets us to 50 so for
30 or 20 in the hole
okay which basically is the a little bit
of depreciation and the amount you were
in the hole before yeah that's what it
amounts to
okay all right hmm well here's the
premise and you're obviously a bright
guy other than this decision but the the
premise is it's very difficult to build
and wealth when you own things that are
very large in ratio to your income that
go down in value so you have a very
large item it's a hundred percent of
your income annually right that's going
down in value and so when it loses 10
percent 15 20 percent in a year that's a
big hit as a percentage of your income
and it makes it very difficult for you
to make progress in your wealth building
you can survive this but but it's just
you're just dooming yourself to being
broke you know because when you turn
sixty thousand bucks into ten thousand
bucks and you make 50 it's hard to
survive that and prosper do you see what
I'm saying mathematically yes and that's
where we're headed with this car I mean
drive it three more years it's gonna be
worth 10 I'm all right yes me might be
worth 12 but I mean it's and a 7 Series
Beemer is a wonderful
in fact I think Beamer is just making a
wonderful product I don't home one today
but I've owned several in my life my
son's got one my daughter's got one
there they're just great cars I think
they're making a good product so it's
not anything about that it's just about
where you are now if you made 200 a year
you know you can afford to take this
kind of hit but you don't so what is
your income prospects what are you going
to be making next year what are you'll
be making the year after what kind of a
an incline is your income on I feel by
next year I should be at um that should
be somewhere around 60 and then after
that I'm hoping to be around 65
well okay you know so this car is is
really bringing you great harm
financially as we're it monster yes
that's what it comes down to it's not
I'm yelling at you it's just you know
it's not it's not a blessing to you it's
occurs until you get in turn the key and
when you're driving at home it's a
blessing because it's a fabulous vehicle
but I'm saying financially
mathematically what it's doing to you is
it's you know it's a curse in your life
it's kind of a it's kind of almost a a
movie scene or something it's like this
beautiful thing this gorgeous item is in
front of you and it's the very thing
that's causing your downfall you see
what I'm saying it's like the temptation
or something you know like then like
Satan is on the other side of this or
something in a movie scene you know I'm
talking about and you just it's like
whoa I will tempt you with this you know
that kind of a thing right and so that
that's because I know this because I'm
you could tell I'm a car guy right I
love cars
and I know this car and you know and I
and so I'm I was tempted in my 20s to do
the same kind of stupid stuff and as a
matter of fact I did I had a Jaguar
couldn't afford and so um I know and I
drove it up in front of my grandpa's
place and he's like a son I put my money
and stuff that goes up in value you
ain't real bright are you
and that was my grandpa right so that's
kind of where I started learning those
lessons so if I'm you I'm getting out of
this car now you know obviously you're
gonna borrow 20 grand to do that and
you're gonna be driving you know a two
thousand dollar car until you get that
20 grand paid off and then you're gonna
save up and buy a car
but dude you gotta amputate the Beemer
okay you see why absolutely okay and
that's not me yelling at you I just want
you to win okay it made sense I just
wanted to know your opinion as because
that was so much negative so much
negative equity if it was worth it yeah
you the problem is it's not gonna get
any better yeah you know key you can
plow through the negative equity as an
unsecured loan and and holding the car
is gonna make the thing compound it's
gonna make the problem compound
mathematically and because the car is
going down while you own it like a rock
you know they all do even great cars go
down in value like a rock so that that's
the thing I want you to have a car
that's a blessing and not a curse thanks
for the call